こんにちははじめ社長です具体的には相手じゃないんですけども調べたことがあるんだ
よそう
愛じゃなくてあれこっちはアイスがホットいうことまぁいいやとりあえずこちらですね
ガリガリ君ソーダ地場レイクアイスではありません
評価で高利貸しという括りになっておりますが猪狩かやー守んなきゃにはたくさんの
距離感があるような
その目指しある理由ってわけじゃないですか踊り食いままで様々な種類の影が出たと
思うんですけどもうこれは思ったすべてのガリガリ君を一つにまとめたと非道のような
味になるかということを俺はに心だしていたいと思ったわけですがいるよね美味しい
です言ったらねキャラットホ
なぜはハートほっ本当においしい暑いと人は概要影響で航空取りでもう一気に体力回復
するわけなんですね今は売って分だけ全種類集めてみました
ガリガリ君ソーダ味京味グレープフルーツオーラビンチミルクこの世界で探せばもっと
あるかもしれないけど俺の初期には男それしかなかっただけでこの5種類を混ぜて何味
になる
かと言うのでちょっと調べてみようと思います舌員が僕のねあのその調べたいという
気持ちで
水十全調べたという僕の層は工賃だけでやってるんで早速開けていきましょうまた
ガリガリ君ソーダ地
ここ巨峰明日ですお前グレープフルーツは受注久美子
うーんまあコーダー地を選んで食べてコーナーで一番好きなんですよ
うん
メルクリッツやつで御ポタージたら7味とかそんな味があるんですけどもう今の季節は
ミルク味なんだろうな一穴こねー
氷のでノーマルの安いほうが美味しいな感じで俺はね入っているこちらのガリガリ君5
種類を合体させて何味になるかというのをちょっと確かめてみようと思います普通に色
もキレイなんですよ
俺こんななんか綺麗な遠かった
あるの久しぶりだないいよ外れいいよキレイなどが綺麗な動画になってきたよみんなも
ね心地よく見れる動画になると思いますで新しいので綺麗な動画ですねこちらの袋にで
ねガリガリ君は1本ずつ入れていきました
[音楽]
ん
はぁ
th
ます
[音楽]
3種
さあコツなのかねが陸混ぜていきましたああ
手や部屋すぐから行くんだけど相手にでなんとか混ぜ終わったんですけどもう ok を
ギャロウウォーカーこんな感じです今国がは前はどのように色になるかが見どころだ
やすごいな
なんか黒美紀さんの髪の毛みたいな色になってきたスネが扱い原宿だねぇ
はいてここで f
我原宿じゃなくなってきたやばいぞから頭じゃない
これはこの色は京都だ今日のようになったがなぜ待って完全に京都だ京都の奇妙リボン
のような色だ俺京都でこのや布なんとか見たことあるから付の次のステップは京都の絹
織物
疲れてるのかこれはホンダ方はこうなぜ kic すればいいんですけども現時点でも
まだ時でないので撮ってれないしてもまた落ちることがないとすることがないのでまだ
アイスでこのまま食べれると思いますいただきます
[音楽]
うまいなぁ甘いですとっても美味しいとっても美味しいんだけども
待て按針の例えばフォントにはかな可児可児郡3町ミルクですね
この魅力がこの月になってその上にコーラそうだ
ぶどうグレープフルーツって乗ってこれはねえうまいぞフルーティー見えるみたいな
フルーツオレみたいだしたね美味しい実に美味しいおいしすぎるので今日の道
が農地は遠くに
ない
[音楽]
dee b